Wir wollen nach acht Spieltagen auf die 2. Bundesliga der Männer schauen, explizit auf den Karlsruher SC und Hannover 96. Und das tun wir jetzt mit Steffi Baczyk vom RBB und Jörn Kreuzer.
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Ja, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ihr kennt mich hier aus dem Rasenfunk, aber sonst eventuell auch von 11 Freunden am Morgen und ich freue mich sehr mit zwei wundervollen Gästen über die zumindest ja kurioseste 2. Liga oder Liga der Welt zu sprechen. Zum einen darf ich in dieser Runde Steffi Baczyk begrüßen, die treue Rasenfunk-HörerInnen und auch Radio-HörerInnen sowieso kennen und auch Sportschauschauerinnen und die glücklicherweise ein bisschen Zeit für uns freischaufeln konnte. Hallo Steffi.
Ja, und das ist, ich glaube, eine Sache, die Stefan Neidl definitiv geschafft hat, ist eben auch das Niedersachsen-Stadion wieder zu füllen mit Fans. Also das war ja auch durchaus eine Zeitlang ein Problem und er hat das zumindest wieder geschafft. Und ich glaube, das war, also und die Heimspiele, die gewinnen sie dann ja auch. Von daher, das ist dann sicherlich auch, der Weg geht auf jeden Fall in die richtige Richtung, lasst es uns so formulieren. Zwei kurze Sachen noch, die ich jetzt einfach doch noch neben dem Platz hinterher schiebe. Ich habe ja gesagt, das spielt jetzt noch kurze Rolle, wollen wir jetzt aber nicht mehr so ausbreiten. Einmal das Thema Fan-Proteste, also nach Ausschreitungen in der letzten saison in den Derbys, hatte ja Niedersachsens Innenministerin Daniela Behrens angekündigt, dass beide Derbys ohne Gäste-Fans stattfinden sollten. Erst Anfang September, nachdem dann auch Braunschweig einen neuen Plan vorgelegt hatte, wie dieses Derby ablaufen könnte. Fehlernahe Entscheidung, dass das Derby zwar mit Gäste-Fans stattfindet, allerdings, dass das Gäste-Kontingent um 40 Prozent reduziert wird. Und es unter anderem auch einen Intro- und Kuriumaterialienverbot geben würde, intensivere Einlasskontrollen, verschärfte Video-Filme. Und daraufhin hat Hannovers Fanszene verkündet, dass sie das Derby boykottieren. Das verfügbare Kontingent wurde auch bei Weitem nicht ausgeschöpft. Ich glaube, 50 Prozent oder so hieß es am Ende. Und eben auch die Braunschweiger-Fanszene hat sich quasi solidarisiert. Auch das ist durchaus ein besonderes Zeichen. Und kündigte zwar an, anwesend zu sein, aber nicht zu supporten, eben weil das ein Eingriff in die Fan-Kultur ist. Und beide Fanszenen hatten dann Demonstrationen angemeldet, am 3. Oktober, am letzten Donnerstag, durch die gegenseitigen Städte, also Hannover in Braunschweig, Braunschweig in Hannover, eben unter der Thematik Populismus entgegentreten für eine freie Fan-Kultur in Niedersachsen und anderswo. Da ist auch alles relativ friedlich verlaufen. Fand ich aber irgendwie dann durchaus doch so ein Novum, dass man sich da so solidarisiert. Und das letzte, was ich gelesen habe, war bei Daniela Behrens selber nicht im Stadion am Sonntag. Das kann man dann auch bewerten, wie man möchte. Weil eben auch gesagt wurde, sollte es da jetzt auch mal Ausschreitungen geben, dann werden eben die nächsten, da bist definitiv ohne Gäste-Fans stattfinden. Für das Rückspiel muss jetzt Hannover ein eigenes Sicherheitskonzept vorlegen. Also das wird immer neu bewertet. Und ja, also generell hat Behrens noch gesagt, die vielen Rückmeldungen aus der Bevölkerung sprechen da eine eindeutige Sprache, dass die Mehrheit der Stadionbesucher sich massiv verunsichert fühlt. Und für die Sicherheit im Stadion sind die Vereine verantwortlich. Die Verantwortung dafür kann nicht von der Polizei wahrgenommen werden. Gut, also ich glaube, es ist eine Thematik. Deshalb haben wir das jetzt so ein bisschen kürzer gemacht. Ich glaube, da könnte man alleine eine halbe Stunde darüber diskutieren, was das alles mit sich zieht. Aber generell finde ich, also wir haben eben auch schon mal über Karlsruhe gesprochen. Auch da gab es sehr viel Solidarität, eben über die Grenzen hinaus, eben mit der organisierten Szene, aber eben auch mit den Fanprojekten. Und auch hier natürlich wieder, also wenn zwei sich wirklich sehr verfeindete Fans sehen, miteinander solidarisieren, weil sie sagen, ey, wir können zwar auf den Tod nicht ausstehen, aber ein Derby ist halt nur Derby, wenn wirklich beide Fans sehen, auch irgendwie anwesend sind und ihr Ding machen können. Das fand ich schon durchaus bemerkenswert. Und dann noch eine letzte Sache, weil Kind schwebt immer ein bisschen im Raum. Aber ich glaube auch da, ich glaube, da könnte man wahrscheinlich drei Tribünengespräche mit erfüllen. Deshalb da auch nur ganz kurz. Seit, ich glaube, gestern ist Martin Kinds Sohn Matthias nicht mehr Teil des Aufsichtsrats bei Hannover 96. Und viel wichtiger vom BGH-Urteil vom 16. Juli diesen Jahres. Martin Kind ist nicht mehr Geschäftsführer von Hannover 96. Die Abberufung von vor zwei Jahren war also rechtskräftig. Es ist aber wirklich, ich sage es euch ganz ehrlich, sowohl Steffi als auch mir fehlt einfach juristisch das Background-Wissen, um das vernünftig zu erklären. Und ich würde mich da auch nicht wohlfühlen, da einfach irgendwelche anderen Sätze oder anderen journalistischen Mitteln einfach komplett abzulesen, weil das müsste ich am Ende des Tages machen. Da ist einfach meine, ja, mein Verständnis für es da leider zu gering. Und das könnte ich da nicht so richtig rüberbringen. Ich kann aber so viel sagen, vom Aufsichtsratvorsitzenden des EV wurde im kompletten Verlauf unter anderem der DFB und die DFL für mangelnde Unterstützung des Muttervereins kritisiert, Thema 50 plus 1. Und man sagt auch, so richtig traut man dem Rat noch nicht, dass da ihm die Ruhe einkehrt, also kein Grund zu feiern. Und ich würde euch tatsächlich ausnahmsweise mal einen Artikel von 11 Freunde in den Show Notes verlinken, wo eben ja das nochmal aufgedröselt wird, wie es um Hannover nach diesem BGH-Ruhe-Teil steht. So, so viel neben dem Platz. Ich habe es jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen abgekürzt. Ich hoffe, das ist für alle Leute in Ordnung. Hannover 96 wird sicherlich nochmal vorkommen und dann können wir es sicherlich nochmal vertiefen. Aber sowohl Steffi als auch mir war es heute einfach mal wichtig, auf das Sportliche zu gucken, weil da gibt es ja genug zu bezählen. Gut, möchtet ihr beide noch was zum Sportlichen zu euren Vereinen loswerden? Das scheint nicht so. Stille.
Wunschlussglücklich.
Das ist schön. Dann von mir noch zwei Sachen. Einmal habe ich Podcast-Empfehlungen für euch dabei. Und zwar die erste. Gestern war der 7. Oktober und Max, also ein Jahr nach dem Angriff der Hamas auf das Nova-Festival und Max hatte im vergangenen Jahr, glaube ich, schon mit Felix Tamsut über die Situation gesprochen. Und ich finde, das ist bis heute ein sehr schönes Tribünengespräch. Hört da gerne noch mal rein. Das verlinke ich euch. Und dann von Feminist Shelf Control. Die haben eine Episode rausgebracht. Unter anderem, die ja den Prozess in Frankreich thematisiert, über die Massenvergewaltigung, die da stattgefunden hat. Und ja, auch über diverse Themen, über das Patriarchat, etc. Ich fand es eine sehr hörenswerte Folge. Daher würde ich euch das auch einmal in die Show notes packen. Wer möchte, kann sich das gerne anhören. Und dann sind wir am Ende dieser Folge. Das heißt, als allererstes möchte ich da unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern danken. Dieser Podcast ist und bleibt Paywall, Werbe- und Sponsorenfrei. Dieser Podcast wird finanziert durch euch, lebt durch euch. Ihr könnt euch informieren über rasenfunk-supporters.club, wie das funktioniert. Ihr finanziert damit die schönen Gäste, die hier sitzen. Ihr finanziert aber eben auch das Marc und ich hier jetzt sitzen. Und ein stellvertretender Dank geht dafür an Highlord Alarak, LordMods Ferdinand, Bernhard, Dominik und Meti85. Ihr seid Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Vielen, vielen Dank dafür. Guckt auch gerne vorbei. Wir haben so viele Formate. Ich glaube, was hier schon wieder alles rausgekommen ist, ich glaube, übermorgen erscheint ein Schwerpunkt zum VfW Bochum. Und dann würde ich mich jetzt bei meinen Gästen bedanken. Vielen Dank Steffi, dass du dabei warst.
Sehr gerne, hat ganz viel Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich und lieben Dank auch Jörn aka Haus of Karlsruhe, Experte, Hofberichterstatter. Danke Jörn.
Sehr gerne und danke, dass ich dabei sein durfte.
Dann wünsche ich euch viel Spaß bei der Folge. Ich hoffe, sie hat euch Spaß gemacht.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank.
Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.